Warren Cave.
Member of the press here
to see a Level 2.
(Music)
Poppy Parnell, is an
investigative journalist who's
career was made on a very
high profile case.
Guard:
Open 2.
Octavia Spencer:
Through her writing she had a
boy from a very affluent neighborhood
Octavia Spencer:
tried as an adult.
News reporter:
Sixteen year old Warren Cave was
taken into custody.
Octavia Spencer:
He was ultimately found guilty
of murdering his neighbor.
Octavia Spencer:
And 19 years later she has to
face
Octavia Spencer:
whether or not she helped to
send an innocent man to prison.
Arron Paul:
When Poppy comes to Warrens
rescue
he is apprehensive and
definitely has his guard up.
Why are you here?
I think I can help you this
time.
(Music)
Poppy is a Podcaster,
Nichelle Tramble Spellman:
and she's a media celebrity who
has all the trappings of success
Nichelle Tramble Spellman:
and came from very humble
beginnings.
She finds out that there was a
case she was involved with years
ago.
Nichelle Tramble Spellman:
And new evidence has come
forward.
The case against Warren was
largely circumstantial.
Guard:
Chin up, turn right.
Poppy Parnerll:
Police did not have a witness to
the actual attack.
Poppy Parnerll:
And Chucks wife Erin, along with
twin daughters Josie and Lanie,
Poppy Parnerll:
had slept through the slaughter.
Jamie Owen:
I play twins Josie and Lanie
whose father was killed.
Jenno Topping:
The twins are kind of locked in
this eternal dynamic with one another.
Completely overwhelmed and often
trapped by familial
constructions of the past.
Everybody's life stopped, in
one way or another, the night of
that murder.
You know how every few years a
vulture comes out of the
woodwork and starts asking about my dad?
What now?
Poppy Parnell is somebody who
just wants to find the truth.
She's jumping wholeheartedly
into it without really
understanding all the facts.
Bret Cullen:
And she creates a great deal of
turmoil and pain.
Ms. Parnell, I'm asking you to
stop.
I can't do that.
Lauren Neustadter:
This podcast
unearths all of these different things and causes people to
Lauren Neustadter:
reckon with a lot of stuff that
they maybe haven't resolved from their past.
Poppy has created a lot of
problems.
Stop talking to that woman.
What are you hiding?
She has to ask herself at every
turn: Am I doing these for the
right reasons?
Am I just trying to find the
truth so badly it destroys
everybody else?
Your eyes are way off the main
goal here.
I'm just going after the truth.
But we're playing with peoples
lives here, Pop.
Are you ready for the
consequences?
It was important for her to go
against everything, I mean
everything, to get to the truth.
(Music)
You think all the secrets came
out during the trial?